please welcome from couple a sitter
welcome welcome to suck on thank you so
much I'm writing me for your and your
show it's great to have you here um in
in this in this clip we saw one of your
four daughters yeah um youyou you chose
to raise her as a boy why was that uh
actually certain reason behind of this
decision because enough horas son
unfortunately still there count female
sex as a second sex of the society so we
have law we have constitution there
already right there that they all human
have equal draw but unfortunately is not
in reality but after this is one of the
reason behind of this issue because i
don't have son and there's a lot of
pressure over me from my husband from
the society that okay you are a hiring
official person you have a good job you
have good position but unfortunately
don't have son and from other side you
know each day in my country the freedom
of women cat and so unfortunately we are
going back to the conflict situation so
to give more freedom for one of my
daughters and to show for the society
that son and daughter doesn't matter and
a girl also can't play the role of boy
for you and candace can give the same
expression so that's why i thought it
will be better to change one of my
daughter to the girl first of all to
stop the gossip around me at my husband
pressure to get another child and also
the third point to give more freedom for
one of my daughters and also get some
protection for their for her older
sister because when now is that how
could how could it give protection you
saw uh if I not introduce so she looked
like a boy so when she go outside and
iPhone society so Muharram it's very
important like I have a main body being
with you to protect you to be with you
to support you but now you can see
Terrell on television and talk about
this and she's she's still I mean she's
11 years old now
she's still still a boy from time to
time and she has short hair and yeah and
but people people in your family and
neighborhood and and around do they know
that do they believe she's a boy that
you got a boy or is it just by the
elution couldn't keep this thing a
secret from everyone yes of course the
close family derivative then no but the
surprise point is here that everybody
treat her like a sound like a boy and
it's even if they know that years ago
it's not only in my family because in
Afghanistan is a normal practice been
for centuries and still continue why
because because of lack of security
because of poor economy because of the
culture barrier because of gender
segregation so let's continue for a
different reason but my mind is not just
a for hoping to have a son or like I
have another men and the whole home I
want to just show for them that please
do not make this fake imagination so
just that i want to show for the society
and for my husband let's see agar can
play the role of the boy and you never
saw that boy will wear the dress of the
girl and look like a girl and my society
at least i'm sure sir being there so but
that's that i just want to show for them
that not count girl as a weakest
generation or as a weakest six on the
society
I don't in you will she pretend or you
know act we started when shipping its
age of six and right now she's 11 years
old and now it's totally depend to her f
xi lian continue in this way I will
support her totally but she knows that
she's a girl and soon she will grow up
already she grew up from this picture
that you saw so it was in 2010 so now
she's 11 years old and she really liked
it now as a young man look like a young
man but if she liked to continue in this
way I will support her definitely think
it's very brave thank you you have a big
family you're a part of a big family
your husband has two wives you're one of
them has there been a lot of discussions
about this at home oh you mean for to
change her yeah to do to judge her job
actually yes Miran was totally engaged
in all discussion we set with her we
told her and we thought that okay this
is a temporary situation will be just
for now to give a little more freedom
for you to give oh it's not good to say
actually to give have more value for the
family for now on and the temporary
situation and also to give support for
your sister would you like to be our son
and he taught with herself and I'm
remember the reaction doesn't allow its
mean that after this go outside play
volleyball play cricket fight with the
boys oh I like it let's do it this this
is this is this is I believe it it's
called much apush yes and it's a it's
quite common isn't it yes at this call
it been common and still it's common